Disney's Wreck-It Ralph was a veritable easter
eggstravaganza for video game nerds, especially
those that spent half their lives in the arcade
during the '80s and '90s.
Here's a look at some of the things in the
film only adults will have noticed.
There's a lot going on with the two policemen
characters introduced in the Sugar Rush realm.
The pair serve the tyrannical King Candy,
meaning they're pretty fast and loose with
their use of tasers and batons, which reads
a bit like a statement in itself, especially
when factoring in the Surge Protector's "random"
screening stops with Ralph.
"Awwww."
"Step aside, sir.
Random security check."
"Random security check my behind, you always
stop me."
"I'm just a surge protector doing my job,
sir.”
Not to mention their motto is "to heat and
serve," which is pretty close to the usual
law enforcement credo of "to protect and serve."
On a lighter note, they're also shaped like
a donut and an eclair, and are named and Duncan
as an homage to Winchell's Doughnut House
and Dunkin' Donuts.
To children, they may seem like any of the
other personified edibles running around the
game, but their parents are sure to get a
chuckle out of this somewhat unsubtle play
on the whole "cops like donuts" stereotype.
Generation Z-ers might be inclined to fixate
on some of the more contemporary references
scattered about the screen in Wreck-It Ralph,
things like Dance Dance Revolution, Bowser
from Super Mario Bros. and the Halo-esque
soldiers riffed on in Hero's Duty.
But there are some background characters with
much longer histories.
Frogger, Street Fighter, and Sonic the Hedgehog
are probably still mainstream enough to ring
a bell for most people.
Some of the more obscure characters in the
film, however, include Tapper's bowtie-wearing
bartender and.
And while fully-grown filmgoers might find
their fingers glued to the pause button as
they scour the screens for these hidden gems,
the younger crowd probably doesn't care about
a bunch of 8-bit oldies.
Even the most obvious game reference of all
in Wreck-It Ralph could be easily missed by
anyone who wasn’t around for the glory days
of the earliest arcade systems.
Fix-It Felix is purely a cinematic creation,
but was undoubtedly inspired by Donkey Kong,
which debuted in 1981 on an arcade machine
that also featured the debut of Jumpman, otherwise
known as Mario.
Donkey Kong as a character will still be familiar
to today's device-wielding whippersnappers,
since he appears in modern games like Mario
Kart and Super Smash Bros., so it's probably
not too surprising that his hulking size,
brute strength, and general oafishness inspired
a lot of Ralph's physical and personality
traits.
It's Fix-It Felix's mission and play style
that really bears a striking resemblance to
the old Donkey Kong, though.
"Anyhoo, what else?
Uh…
I'm a wrecker.
I wreck things, professionally."
"I'm gonna wreck it!”
In both games, the do-gooder is charged with
climbing a large structure while the villain
tosses debris down at them.
They might not be exactly the same, but, well,
they practically are.
It's not until the tail end of Wreck-It Ralph
that audiences find out the film features
another Disney Princess to add to the collection.
But even after she's suited up in a ball gown,
Vanellope Von Schweetz handles this fact very
differently than her forebears.
Sure, there are a few theoretical similarities
to the princesses of old: she's been deprived
of her title by an evildoer, gets bullied
by a bunch of mean girls and is frequently
told that her eccentricities, in this case,
glitches, are troublesome.
So far, so Disney Princess.
Unlike her peers, however, Vanellope has no
interest in wearing the crown.
"I was here.
I was there.
I was glitchin' through the walls.
I'm not giving that up."
For the most part, there's nothing stereotypically
princessy about her; she's feisty, resourceful,
determined and has absolutely no interest
in living a prim life of privilege.
Not only that, but there's nary a love interest
in sight either, and while Ralph does help
her fulfill her dream of earning a spot in
the big race, she does a lot of the legwork
herself.
The Diet Coke and Mentos geyser gag that saves
the day in Wreck-It Ralph is based on a real
trend that became big in the mid-aughts after
an on-air demonstration of the effect went
viral, subsequently inspiring an episode of
MythBusters.
For those who grew up ahead of the internet
age, though, there was a much earlier version
of the messy at-home experiment that everyone
just had to try.
Way back when, it was the Wint-O-Green flavored
Lifesavers that kids would drop into their
soda bottles to set off a massive liquid eruption.
That was just one of the many food-item combination
challenges that would get around by word of
mouth in the '90s.
So while the candy-soda combo trick in Wreck-It
Ralph may be a convenient plot device that
kids can shrug their shoulders at, the older
crowd might just get a tinge of nostalgia
after seeing it come into use.